Vi propongo anche io un esperimento
anche se non sono
mai riuscito a portarlo a termine.
Un esperimento... questo è un foglietto
sarà spesso più o meno
due decimi di millimetro
Ok, allora lo metto giù, ci salgo sopra
e sono due decimi più alto.
Lo piego... mi rendo conto,
non è un grande esperimento però...
Lo piego, adesso sono quattro decimi.
Lo piego ancora e sono quasi un millimetro.
Immagino che nessuno di voi abbia notato
la differenza in altezza.
Ecco, adesso deduciamo due ipotesi.
Supponiamo di impiegare cinque secondi
ogni volta che pieghiamo il fogliettino
e supponiamo anche
che noi riusciamo sempre a piegarlo.
Ecco, quello che succede
è che dopo due minuti
noi saremo in grado di realizzare
uno spessore che ci permette
di raggiungere circa
tre chilometri e 300 metri
Cioè la cima di una Marmolada per dire.
Se invece noi impieghiamo 205 secondi
saremo in grado di creare
una zeppetta che potremo inserire
tra la terra e la luna
Ecco, questo è il fenomeno
dell'esponenzialità, cioè, qualcosa
che all'inizio parte timidamente
e poi cresce
Se noi prendiamo....
Se noi prendiamo...
... guardiamo gli andamenti della tecnologia,
gli indici teconologici
potremo vedere che aumentano
in maniera esponenziale, questo è un grafico
in cui vengono rappresentati
i record di velocità dei robot bipedi
prometto, è il primo e ultimo grafico
che mostrerò,
si vede l'andamento esponenziale all'inizio,
poi ad un certo punto
l'esponenzialità finisce
e bisogna aspettare ulteriori anni
per creare un nuovo paradigma.
Ora quello che è strano
è che le menti non lavorano
in maniera esponenziale,
le menti ci impiegano tanto tempo
per generare un'idea
e quindi ci si chiede, da dove si riesce
a passare dal lineare della mente
all'esponenziale della tecnologia
o di un prodotto tecnologico.
Beh la risposta è in questa slide,
che ovviamente non è la slide giusta
però non è giusta
perché questa è una polpetta cotta.
Invece noi dobbiamo pensare
a una polpetta cruda.
Ecco, se noi immaginiamo un'idea
come una polpetta cruda, una grande idea,
immaginiamo un vassoio di pan grattato,
la tecnologia,
l'evoluzione della tecnologia è questo:
far passare l'idea, fare in modo che la polpetta
rotolando si attacchi alle idee pregresse
Ora, un nuovo paradigma, una nuova idea
non è di per sé un prodotto,
non genera un incremento,
ma unendosi a tutte le idee pregresse
genera un prodotto, un'innovazione nuova.
Ecco, quello che succede è che all'inizio
ci sono molte briciole di pane a disposizione
un pò alla volta la polpetta si satura e quindi
abbiamo saturato l'indice della esponzialità.
Questo è un esempio,
negli anni 70, in centro vedete,
è stata ideata, si è pensato,
la polpetta della ruota unidirezionale
che permetteva a una piattaforma aerobotica
di muoversi in qualsiasi direzione
e poi è stata applicata alle automobili,
ai robot che giocano a calcio,
ai robot di servizio e via dicendo.
Ecco, questo è il valore di una polpetta che rotola.
Ora, banalmente si potrebbe dire, ok,
qual è il motore delle polpette?
Chi fa rotolare le polpette?
Si potrebbe dire che il motore siano i soldi
ma c'è anche un altro fattore
secondo me molto più importante: la felicità.
Concordo con coloro che dicono che la felicità
può essere suddivisa in due tipi di felicità:
la felicità edonistica e l'immagine a sinistra,
questa volta corretta
non ha bisogno di spiegazioni.
Invece esiste un'altra felicità
cosiddetta felicità di flusso
cioè, quella felicità che permette di essere felici
quando si riesce a portare a termine
un compito difficile ma riuscendoci,
altrimenti c'è frustrazione.
ecco che in questo caso,
si ottiene il raggiungimento di felicità
attraverso l'unione di più idee,
quindi facendo rotolare la polpetta.
Questo dà un grosso input di felicità
nel nostro cervello.
Ecco, dove ho partorito questa idea?
Ecco là mi vedete a sinistra.
Ho avuto la fortuna di stare due anni in Sud Sudan,
una terra che ha una modalità di felicità
completamente diversa dalla nostra.
Là la felicità è basata sulle vacche,
si è felici quando nasce un vitello,
si è infelici quando muore una vacca,
si è molto infelici quando ti rubano le vacche,
quando un uomo si sposa
e quindi spende molte vacche
per comprare la moglie,
è molto infelice e molto felice contemporaneamente.
Ecco, vi posso assicurare,
lo posso dire con certezza
che una tale etnia del Sud Sudan
non conosce le polpette,
questo è un dato di fatto.
Non le conosce sia quelle fisiche,
sia quelle metaforiche che indicano
l'evoluzione della tecnologia.
Loro non sanno che farsene
della combinazione di più idee,
di cercare più idee
combinandole insieme per cercare la felicità.
È una cosa strana
perché mi è capitato proprio in una terra in cui
c'era l'assenza completa
di questo criterio per essere felici
per rendermi conto quanto questo criterio
era insito in me in Italia,
quando ero in Italia.
Se si va a guardare più in dettaglio
ci si accorge che c'è
un sottile legame tra il concetto di felicità
durante le varie epoche,
il periodo ellenistico, medioevo,
rinascimento e via dicendo
e i vari incrementi di tecnologia
che sono avvenuti in quei periodi là.
Quindi è molto più sottile
di quanto sembra il legame.
Vista così è chiaro
che la felicità legata alla teconologia
può far sembrare la vita come un gioco.
E arrivato a questo punto della mia vita
mi sono reso conto
che a me personalmente non
interessano gli ingredienti delle polpette
ma interessa far rotolare le polpette.
Da piccolo mi divertivo
a incastrare gli oggettini dentro gli oggetti
e mi rendo conto che adesso sono felice
quando riesco a far rotolare una polpetta.
Certo che tutto questo può far sorridere:
combinare un qualcosa di profano come una polpetta
con qualcosa di così serio come lo creatività,
soprattutto la creatività imprenditoriale.
Però è anche vero che ridere delle cose serie
è una attività edificante, se non l'unica,
per rendersi conto che la vita
non è altro che un susseguirsi
di eventi risibili,
trattati a volte con eccessiva serietà.
(Applausi)